day 35 um
still uh
encouraged by my um
increasing sense of control over korean
speaking uh with uh mr chung the uh
editor of jung ilbo yesterday
and noticing it again in my reading and
listening
so that kind of always spurs you to more
activity when you feel you're getting
somewhere
so i spent
about an hour and a half or so on link
saving words and phrases linking
one was this article that
again one of my viewers told me about
which was
kim yong-ha
giving a ted ted speech
in
korean with the transcript which we then
loaded into our library at link so i
went through that
and then there was a new item one of the
items that our member imani is sharing
which was uh
uh in the series uh about uh economics
and they talked about advertising and
and so forth and each one of these about
18 minutes long
and so however many words that is i went
through creating lots of links
uh
and then with that i took off uh to go
skiing
and while it's six seven eight degrees
here down in below half an hour away it
was snowing and there was lots of snow
on the trails and i skied and i listened
uh a few times to each one of these
uh not really understanding it of course
even though i had gone through and
picked out all the words that i didn't
know so theoretically i had some sense
of all these words but
i still can't pick it out when they're
talking i have a sense of what they're
talking about
uh and then
i went through and i all of those links
that i created now on my ipad i go
through them as
flash cards
not in the hope that i'm going to learn
them or remember them but just to help
me notice just to help me notice and i
move the status of a number of them up
to known that i'm now quite familiar
with
and then the last thing i'm going to do
after dinner is to read
both of those 18-minute episodes on my
ipad
and i'll probably have to stay with
those two items for another day or so to
start to feel more comfortable with that
content
but i have just a better feeling all
around
uh which is nice it's 35 days in and i'm
beginning to see noticeable progress i
had a look at on our
website at link on the exchange section
to see how others are doing
now i'm working quite hard but there's
quite a few people who are more active
than i am who have higher
uh activity numbers on our site
and there's one thing about language
learning and and why i've always felt
that one should measure activity level
rather than some
test of whether you can
you know get the subjunctive right or
whatever they test you for
if a person is active with the language
active listening reading writing
speaking reviewing
there will be results i've been quite
convinced that there's a direct
relationship between the activity level
and your progress in the language now
some people may have some parts of
their skill set improved faster than
others but overall if we put in the
activity we will improve
and so it's heartening to see uh those
people with that high activity level and
maybe at some point some
you know later on we'll start to see
some
people come forward and
talk about how much they felt they
improved as a result of participating in
the challenge so that's all for today
bye